[Musica]
[Applauso]
Buonasera
del 2000 a 23 anni
decido di avviare la professione di
progettista grafico
mi reco presso la Camera di Commercio di
Siracusa
per avviare l'attività
e mi accorgo con stupore
che non esiste la categoria progetto
grafico graphic design o progettista
grafico
rientro in una categoria definita altre
attività di disegnatori grafici grafica
pubblicitaria e illustrazione questo
perché non abbiamo un albo non abbiamo
una categoria professionale che solo nel
2013 si è riuscita tramite il Ministero
dello Sviluppo Economico a svolgere
attività professionale
Questo è il prologo
tento di aprire un'attività ma a in quei
tempi era difficile
complicato anche da un punto di vista
economico
Quindi decido di avviare l'attività nel
salotto di casa dei miei genitori
mi munisco di una scrivania
low cost potremmo dire oggi un computer
Windows il Mac costava troppo in quei
tempi forse ancora adesso una tastiera e
un mouse
PS2 un ingresso che oggi non esiste più
visto che abbiamo è wireless un monitor
triniton tubo catodico di 10 kg e
acquisto quelle licenze di software
necessari per la progettazione sia di
grafica e soprattutto dei caratteri i
caratteri hanno una licenza
quelli che noi vediamo Nei computer nei
video terminali hanno una licenza che
servono esattamente per pagare chi
progetta quei caratteri
Ma questo aggeggio stupendo storico
modem a 56K
prima connessione quindi lunghe anche
solo per connettersi e col mitico rumore
di composizione telefonica che quando
qualche componente della famiglia alzava
il telefono era sempre occupato si
staccava era una
per testimoniare che avevo 23 anni
Questo sono io
monitor trinitron
tastiera
Meno male e monitor il mouse PS2
la scrivania low cost con il mitico
carrellino per portare il posto la
tastiera e inizio chiaramente a
progettare
In quegli anni ebbe la fortuna anche di
avere una prima supplenza presso
l'Istituto stradale d'arte di Siracusa
dove avevo frequentato mi ero diplomato
in maturità d'arte applicati metalli
oreficeria
e in quel momento questa supplenza di 9
ore oggi potremmo dire mezza cattedra mi
permise di essere a contatto con docenti
curatori autori
il preside di quel tempo mi disse ma se
tu fai il grafico ti affido un progetto
grafico quindi iniziai a progettare il
mio primo catalogo il mio primo
esperimento soprattutto di con un ente
pubblico nel
gli strumenti erano diversi non c'era
tutta la tecnologia e la tecnologia in
quel momento era raccolta in un oggetto
libro composto da segnature
sciolte raccolte La Stampa l'inchiostro
tutto quello che si poteva apprendere
non si trovava su Wikipedia tutto Quella
Conoscenza come definita da Socrate
si trovava inquilibri e con quegli
strumenti di quel tempo il tipometro il
contafili i campionari dei caratteri e
soprattutto la progettazione grafica
avveniva diversamente ovvero
con un metodo la progettazione di un
catalogo avveniva tramite un merabo la
raccolta di tutto quel materiale
testuale ancora arrivava dattiloscritto
le immagini non erano in digitale
diapositive 35 mm foto una logica
acquisizioni da scanner Quindi tutto il
processo non poteva essere se non bene
progettato ma soprattutto organizzato
l'organizzazione del cuore della nostra
disciplina quella del mestiere del
grafico
alle ore 20:30 arrivano queste cotoletta
alla salvia presso il mio studio salotto
perché sia io che Il curatore Abbiamo
fame Quindi mia madre ci Apparecchia nel
nostro salotto di casa questa
piccola scena affinché Il curatore
iniziamo a progettare e terminiamo alle
4 e 30 del mattino
da lì capisco che fosse il grafico non
dorme riposa ovvero che il tempo è
talmente
veloce che scorre e scorre
esclusivamente per perché ci piace
quello che facciamo progettare non è un
lavoro Progettare un gioco un mestiere
di responsabilità
ma soprattutto da qualcosa
chi oggi decide di progettare lo deve
fare sicuramente per lasciare un
qualcosa
Questo è quello che esce un catalogo
Chiaramente oggi potrei dire lo avrei
fatto diversamente ma sono passati 23
anni ma è lì in una libreria in una
biblioteca è sempre presente e in corpo
8 c'è scritto nel colon progetto grafico
Gianni latino può essere un prodotto
senza tempo può essere un prodotto che
sicuramente è un divulgatore culturale
in questo caso di una mostra sul Gaggini
il titolare della
dell'allora istituto d'arte di Siracusa
il fondatore quindi ha una testimonianza
diretta
nel 2003 riesco a ad aprire lo studio un
garage 40 metri quadri
due stanze all'interno di queste due
stanze porto sempre L'essenziale ma
quello che viene sempre con me comincia
a aumentare sono i libri perché libri
fanno parte di quello che è la nostra
prima vera
professione c'è quella di conoscere
prima di progettare
comprendere prima di progettare
all'interno di questo contesto cambia la
tipologia di del progettista Cioè mi
rivolgo al pubblico Mi rivolgo Quindi al
semplice cittadino che passava
all'interno di questo mio basso dove
c'era scritto il mio nome Gianni latino
il minuscolo era una citazione del
Bauhaus la prima scuola di Democratica
di arte design chiusa nel 33 dal nazismo
e una un'altra citazione era l'asterisco
questa asterisco che si richiamava la
cultura delle cancellazioni ai rimandi
al frontespizio che si andava a inserire
e si inserisce ancora nei libri
Quindi queste citazioni non bastavano a
far capire passanti cosa facevo
Mi hanno scambiato per un avvocato
gustavano mi hanno scambiato per un
elettricista per un medico tutte
mestieri che chiaramente non facevo
ma passavano anche le donne più anziane
che mediamente ogni due mesi mi
chiedevano la fotocopia della bolletta
dell'Enel delle cose e io gliela
facciamo
questo perché il concetto del del
progettista non arriva non arriva perché
tutti sanno che c'è un computer Tutti
sanno che possono avere una scrivania e
possono iniziare a progettare Ma la
progettazione è una ricerca questa
ricerca che ho avviato inizialmente con
dei prodotti commerciali ma non ero
contento sono riuscito a progettare menu
di pizzerie locali
negozi ma mi mancava qualcosa cioè
ovvero mi mancava quello che sempre
all'interno della mia formazione
era quello di lasciare qualcosa cioè
lasciare il segno cercare di essere
utile per la società per il cittadino e
per fruitore
e quindi decisi di dire no a quei
prodotti che io non ci credevo e quei
prodotti che pensavano che io devo
obbedire a quei prodotti commerciali a
quei prodotti che falsificavano e
sfalsavano la società e il messaggio
quindi
bisognava educare la committenza a
quello che era il ruolo del progettista
cioè che da un mestiere tra contenuta e
contenitore
la mia formazione si è basata
principalmente su una frase che mi ha
ancora oggi la porto con me di albe
Steiner al vestane è stato un grafico
partigiano che oggi è uno dei più grandi
è stato uno più grande protagonista
della cultura italiana insieme a
Vittorini nel '45 fondarono il
Politecnico e quella la nuova cultura
che era l'idrale di delle Vittorini era
la nuova grafica di albe Steiner
diceva che il grafico non è un venditore
di fumo la sua una vera specializzazione
Ecco queste parole mi tornavano sempre
quindi chiusi col commerciale mi sentivo
quasi inutile verso la società Ma perché
devo progettare mi accorsi che la
progettazione per me è diventata una
necessità adesso cioè si progetta la
qualsiasi cosa anche le vacanze anche
l'andare a cena c'è un buon progetto
base da una buona si basa su una buona
organizzazione
nella progettazione
iniziamo a capirsi Che cos'erano anche
le mostre
Umberto Eco definì questo campo l'altra
grafica l'altra grafica che non guarda
alla alle merci al consumo che guarda
esattamente al pubblico a progetti
culturali lavorare a favore della
cultura
in quell'anno mi recai presso la
galleria regionale di Palazzo Bellomo e
dissi di mi proporrei come grafico è la
direttrice un illuminata di quel tempo
nel 2003 mini disse Ok collaboriamo
e da lì iniziai a collaborare progettare
mostre di
qualsiasi argomento inizia a capire che
cos'era esattamente Il curatore
l'allestitore il grafico redattore il
tipografo gli autori i curatori gli
architetti tutti insieme per una sola
causa quella di progettare per il
pubblico ovvero
avvicinare il fruitore Il Cittadino a
quello che è un progetto culturale
ma il cittadino è il primo a essere il
nostro giudice quindi la progettazione
deve essere chiara semplice immediata
senza giri di parole
mostre in diversi luoghi della cultura
passai da Caravaggio passai alla mostra
su 700 musica picta e la cosa bella è
vedere il proprio manifesto in giro per
le strade
para pedonali tutto ciò che era
possibile diciamo
comunicare attraverso l'artefatto era
quello quel segnale che quel fruitore
capiva che lì c'era una mostra
il
uno degli eventi più interessanti che mi
ha
completato la mia formazione e nel 2010
Quando
entro in accademia e insegno graphic
design
capisco che gli studenti erano l'altra
grafica all'interno di quel contesto che
mi riusciva a completare il loro
entusiasmo diventò la mia forza e
insieme iniziamo a progettare a
progettare per il territorio con
centenari celebrazioni tutte quelle che
ci permettevano di poter all'interno
e far capire che cos'era il mestiere di
grafico come lo si chiamava Nel 33
quindi il mestiere di grafico non è
altro che oggi un
ruolo all'interno della società portante
davvero protagonista che permette anche
di cambiare il mondo anche attraverso un
manifesto anche attraverso un segno
grafico perché la grafica nasce per
questo nasce per comunicare dove c'è
grafica c'è comunicazione dove c'è
comunicazione c'è grafica
il
il contesto in cui si vive con gli
studenti È straordinario non si può
descrivere ci divertiamo Ecco il
divertimento si va sostituito a quello
che si chiama lavoro io mi alzo O forse
non dormo in base a quando
inizio a lavorare a progettare e quindi
il tempo passa il tempo passa perché c'è
divertimento
vedere anche lo studente che si mette in
primo piano si spende su quello che
potrebbe essere una divulgazione di una
mostra di una vocazione di un progetto è
quello quello che completa
quindi il progettista grafico non è uno
spettatore
è un protagonista Direi un testimone
rivoluzionario intellettuale della
collettività
e all'interno della Formazione culturale
del grafico si fondono due saperi il
sapere della mano e il sapere del
cervello
il sapere umanistico è il sapere tecnico
scientifico questi intreccio forma
l'artigiano intellettuale
o potremmo dire il progettista organico
come Gramsci definiva intellettuali a
favore della cultura a favore della
città
tutto questo è quello che si racconta
quando qualcuno osservo un manifesto
il cittadino è il primo giudice
quindi un manifesto
può esattamente comunicare può
emozionare
come in questo caso
siamo a Bergamo una serie di grafici
nazionali e internazionali
progettarono per il settantesimo
anniversario della carta dei diritti
umani Quindi ogni grafico
propose la sua idea il suo messaggio
quindi il grafico o il progettista
grafico
può cambiare il mondo
purché abbia due costanti il contenuto
il contenitore
con etica e responsabilità civile Grazie
[Applauso]